Назва цих німецьких бронемашин у Німеччині нині у всіх на слуху. БМП "Мардер".
Саме цю бронетехніку, а також танки "Леопарди" та інше важке озброєння Україна хотіла б отримати від ФРН.
Проте у Бундесвері відкинули можливість постачання важкого озброєння Києву.
Проблема в тому, кажуть військові, що німецьким збройним силам самим потрібні ці БМП -
для виконання різних зобов'язань у складі формувань НАТО.
Як заявив заступник генерального інспектора Бундесверу Маркус Лаубенталь,
якщо ці "Мардери" відправлять в Україну, то у Бундесверу не залишиться нічого
для Сил швидкого реагування НАТО у разі потреби.
По суті, конфлікт навколо німецьких важких озброєнь виходить на новий рівень,
раз його коментують уже військові Бундесверу.
Напередодні канцлер Німеччини Шольц заявив, що Берлін допоможе Україні,
але уникнув при цьому слів "важке озброєння".
Ми попросили німецьку військову промисловість повідомити, що саме вона може поставити найближчим часом.
Україна вже зробила вибір із цього списку, і ми надаємо їй гроші, необхідні для покупки.
Ми й надалі виступатимемо на знак солідарності з Україною, країна отримуватиме нашу підтримку.
Але як лідери ми також зобов'язані запобігти розповсюдженню війни на інші країни.
Тому НАТО не може і не буде безпосередньо втручатися у війну. Це рішення залишається чинним. Ми всі з цим згодні.
Посол України в Німеччині Андрій Мельник заявив, що розчарований позицією Берліна.
Він розкритикував заяву канцлера ФРН Олафа Шольца про подальше постачання озброєнь Києву як недостатнє.
За його словами, у списку, який Україна отримала від федерального уряду кілька тижнів тому, взагалі немає важкої зброї.
Тому в Києві не розуміють, на що можуть витратити майже півтора мільярда євро військової допомоги,
якщо необхідну зброю купити не можуть.
У Німеччині вже котрий день триває запекла політична дискусія,
пов'язана з небажанням канцлера Олафа Шольца дати добро на постачання важких озброєнь.
Так, приміром, Зелені, які входять до правлячої коаліції з лібералами та соціал-демократами,
чинять тиск на Олафа Шольца.
Антон Гофрайтер, депутат від Зелених та голова комітету Бундестагу у справах ЄС, заявив,
що небажання Німеччини постачати важке озброєння Україні загрожує ескалацією військового конфлікту.
За його словами, де-факто йде третя світова війна.
Раніше після повернення з поїздки до Львова Гофрайтер критикував канцлера в інтерв'ю DW.
Я можу лише здогадуватися, чому канцлер тисне на гальма.
Я не бачу жодних розумних причин для цього.
Але своїми діями канцлер ФРН шкодить не лише Україні, а й іміджу Німеччини в Європі та в усьому світі, причому дуже серйозно.
А це загрожує збитками геополітичними, іміджевими, а в довгостроковій перспективі й економічними.
А головне, звичайно, це те, що в Україні гинуть люди.
Тому я можу тільки закликати канцлера: припиніть нарешті тиснути на гальма і дайте зелене світло.
Ліберали також кажуть, що уряд Німеччини не повинен зволікати на тлі війни Росії з Україною.
Канцлер заявив, що хоче модернізувати Бундесвер, але водночас підтримати Україну.
Це потрібно реалізовувати послідовно.
Але дискусії в уряді не повинні тривати вічно, тому що війна триває.
Ми повинні діяти швидше, федеральний уряд має швидше ухвалювати рішення.
Ситуація в Берліні склалася вкрай небезпечна, кажуть німецькі політологи.
На їхню думку, це ще не розкол, але він вже близький.
А за розколом у коаліції може бути розпад уряду і гостра політична криза в Німеччині.
І все через постачання важких озброєнь в Україну, а також нездатність німецьких політиків дійти компромісу.
У СДПН тим часом пояснюють, що німецький уряд не приймає рішення одноосібно.
Мовляв, військові постачання узгоджуються зі США та в ЄС.
Я знаю, що наш канцлер і наш уряд ведуть дуже і дуже тісні переговори із союзниками про те, що саме ми постачаємо Україні, що є.
Ми бачимо, що виділяються гроші на те, щоб озброєння можна було купити в іншій країні.
І ми хочемо, щоб постачання в Україну здійснювалося якнайшвидше.
Це те, що я знаю про переговори між главами урядів.
І тому не хочу вести дискусію з послом України публічно, а кажу, що все, що ми можемо зробити, ми зробимо.
Але, звичайно, є відмінності у думках щодо того, чи маємо ми постачати важку зброю чи ні.
І одне із зобов'язань нашого канцлера та й інших глав держав - не допустити втручання НАТО в цей конфлікт.
І це одна із проблем, яку ми маємо вирішити.
Хоча й у самій СДПН немає єдиної думки щодо озброєнь.
Так, голова комітету Бундестагу із зовнішньої політики Томас Рот
виступив за якнайшвидше постачання зброї Україні.